what were you talking about on the
stream what time are you made of time if
I remembered half the things I said on
stream uh someday someone's going to
make a model of all of it I'm just going
to come back to haunt me someday soon
yeah probably
would that be exciting to you or sad
that there's a George hotz model
I mean the question is when the George
hotz model is better than George tots
like I am declining and the model is
growing what is the metric by which you
measure better or worse in that if
you're competing with yourself
maybe you can just play a game where you
have the George hot dance or in the
George Hots model answer and ask which
people prefer
people close to you or strangers
either one it will hurt more when it's
people close to me but
both will be overtaken by the George
hotz model
it'd be quite painful right loved ones
family members would rather have the
model over for Thanksgiving than you
yeah
or like significant others
would rather sext
with the uh with the large language
model version of you
especially when it's fine-tuned to their
preferences
yeah well that's what we're doing in a
relationship right we're just
fine-tuning ourselves but we're
inefficient with it because we're
selfish and greedy and so on our
language models can fine tune more
efficiently more selflessly there's a
Star Trek Voyager episode where uh you
know Catherine Janeway lost in the Delta
quadrant makes herself a lover on the
Holodeck and
um
the lover falls asleep on her arm and he
snores a little bit and you know Janeway
edits the program to remove that
and then of course the realization is
wait this person's terrible it is
actually all there uh nuances and quirks
and slight annoyances that that make
this relationship worthwhile
but I don't think we're going to realize
that until it's too late
well uh I think a large language model
could incorporate the the flaws and the
quarks and all that kind of stuff just
the perfect amount of quirks and floor
flaws to make you charming without
crossing the line yeah yeah
and that's probably a good like
approximation of the like the percent of
time the language model should be uh
cranky or uh
an [__] yeah or jealous or all this
kind of stuff and of course it can and
it will but all that difficulty at that
point is artificial there's no more real
difficulty
okay what's the difference between real
and artificial artificial difficulty is
difficulty that's like constructed or
could be turned off with a knob real
difficulty is like you're in the woods
and you've got to survive
so if something cannot be turned off
with a knob it's real
yeah I think so or I mean you can't get
out of this by Smashing the knob with a
hammer
I mean maybe you kind of can you know I
into the wild when uh you know uh
Alexander Supertramp he wants to explore
something that's never been explored
before but it's the 90s everything's
been explored so he's like well I'm just
not going to bring a map
yeah I mean
no you're you're not exploring you
should have brought a map dude you died
there was a bridge a mile from where you
were camping
how does it connect to the metaphor of
the knob
by not bringing the map you didn't
become an explorer
you just smashed the thing yeah yeah the
art the difficulty is still artificial
you failed before you started what if we
just don't have access to the knob well
that maybe is even scarier
right like we already exist in a world
of Nature and nature has been fine-tuned
over billions of years yeah
um to have uh
humans build something
and then throw the knob away in some
Grand romantic gesture is horrifying